welcome back to cbs this morning
we are hearing from one of jeffrey
epstein's alleged victims
her name is virginia roberts giuffray in
her first interview since guelin maxwell
was denied bail this week
maxwell is accused of helping epstein
sexually abuse underage girls
now this is the first time that maxwell
has faced criminal charges
in connection with epstein despite
accusations against her
that extend back more than two decades
now drew frey claims maxwell along with
epstein recruited
groomed and abused her she lives in
australia now she's married with three
children and we talked to her yesterday
she told us that she thinks guelin
maxwell should spend the rest of her
life
behind bars she is a monster
she's worse than epstein she she did
things
even worse than epstein did she was
vicious
she was evil and she's a woman her
lawyers have said
glenn maxwell is not a jeffrey epstein
that she has been a victim of media spin
they're doing their job but um i know
that woman i've known her
really well put it this way epstein was
pinocchio
and she was gestetto she was the guy
controlling the stream jeffrey
yep she was pulling the strings she had
his money
he had her contacts but guilin was much
more conniving and smart than epstein
ever was virginia roberts dufrese says
she first met jeffrey epstein and gilan
maxwell
when she was just 16. and alleges that
she was forced to have sex with
britain's prince andrew on three
separate occasions
she was 17 at the time he has denied
that and says it's possible this picture
with his arm around her waist
was doctored is there any way
you could have had sex with that young
woman or any young woman trafficked by
jeffrey epstein in any of his residences
no prince andrew should be panicking he
knows he's guilty
he needs to be held accountable we need
to show the world that
the rich and the mighty can fall to do
you think that
guilin's life is in danger absolutely
if she squeals on some of the people
that
she has videos on they won't be happy
with her talking about that and when you
say
that she has videos where she has
knowledge of videos that exist about
people
people like who people well-known names
very well-known names
um you know the government officials the
the politicians
the royalties like you know they were
taping everybody
every moment when you walked into to the
new york mansion
to palm beach everything was being
filmed do you think people
knew they were being taped no no i do
not
not at all duffray alleges maxwell and
epstein were blackmailing the wealthy
and the powerful
she says maxwell's arrest marked a major
turning point
in the fight for justice today we
announced charges against glenn maxwell
for helping jeffrey epstein sexually
exploit and abuse multiple minor
girls it was just surreal it was
momentous it's one of those life moments
that i'll never forget
virginia how did you meet her and what
was her pitch to you
i'm working at mar-a-lago loving it i'm
working in the spa area
i was reading about anatomy and massage
and
and that's when guilin came up to me and
said oh my god you're reading a book
about massage and
you know long story short she told me
that
she knew of a man who was looking for
a traveling masseuse and if he liked me
then i would get educated
and i would become a real massage
therapist
so yeah i mean it was a dream of a
lifetime
until i got there and the abuse was
immediate
it has been reported that they would
prey on young girls
who were vulnerable she could smell the
vulnerability on a person
i told them a little bit about my past
and
and how i'd been abused so immediately
it was like the cheshire smile is what i
call it and i asked her and i said
why are you having all these
girls come in and sleep with your
boyfriend
and she was like so i don't have to do
it all the time you know so she made
like a joke out of it
why do you think she did it she did it
to keep jeffrey happy
for sure
she did it because she loves the control
over people jeffrey was a sick
pedophile but she was the mastermind
what would justice look like for you
when it comes to guilan maxwell
i would like to see guilin stay in jail
forever
i would like her to apologize for what
she's done to me and so many others
when jeffrey epstein took his own life
many of the victim
survivors felt that they had been robbed
that they did not get their day in court
it would have been great to look at him
in court and say
you know you hurt me you took away my
innocence he took away
my youth but he took that away from us
too
i'm really hoping we get to do this with
guillen does a buck stop with galen
maxwell in your opinion
no the buck stops when every single
monster gets held accountable and our
children are
are safe not just my monsters but
all the monsters and we need everyone's
help
maxwell has pleaded not guilty to the
charges against her and denies any
wrongdoing
virginia robert schuffe's claims are not
part of this indictment
maxwell's attorneys declined to comment
on her accusations